good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it
what's your least favorite kind of
animal mice who ward over theme parks
what's your favorite dance move this one
you take this guy up and then do your
dancing I'm dancing yeah I want to
apologize to my printer why does
everyone like ferret so much I don't
know who you're hanging out with but
that is not an issue in my house what's
your favorite photograph this one called
young farmers also sometimes known as
three farmers on their way to a dance
August 1914 there were two dances that
they were on their way to of course the
one they knew about and World War one
how's Willie he's good here you can
watch him for the next several questions
scipios casting yes
Ansel Elgort has been cast as Augustus
waters and hazel grace Lancaster will be
played by shailene woodley but I am a
giant squid of anger about this yeah
that's not a question but I am grateful
that you are passionate about the book
and want it to be a good movie but you
have to understand I also want it to be
a good movie and I've actually seen the
auditions and you aren't going to think
oh that's shailene woodley or oh that's
the guy who plays Caleb Pryor in
divergent you're just gonna think oh
that's hazel and Gus how much say do you
actually have in casting a surprising
amount I mean I'm definitely not casting
the movie but the producers in the
director have been really really nice
about including me in everything what'd
you think at the Gatsby movie yeah hey
what would you do if you were invisible
for an hour I would go to the emergency
room I mean I'm pretty hypochondriasis
uh Dhin Lee became invisible would
proceed with some haste to the nearest
health care provider and be like why am
i invisible I googled it but there is
nothing in the medical literature
perhaps we should do a cat scan how many
times a day do you check your cell phone
I'm sorry what's that are you good at
multitasking studies consistently show
that the better people think they are at
multitasking the worse they actually are
and I am great at it how's it feel to be
a doctor about the same as it felt
before actually did they let you keep
your Cape thing did they I've hardly
taken it off by the way it is
technically known as a Cape thing would
you rather fight a rabid badger or
Nicolas Cage well I'm gonna have to know
more about the badgers at a regular
badger or honey badgers it's like a baby
badger if it's a regular baby badger I'm
gonna take the rabid badger otherwise
definitely Nic Cage if you could only
recommend one book to nerdfighteria what
would it be
that changes weekly at the moment my
recommendation for zombie novels is the
end games by T Michael Martin for non
zombie novels I'm gonna recommend how to
get filthy rich in rising Asia if I were
to gift you a Pegasus what color would
you like it to be which and that's very
nice of you but I do not want a Pegasus
first there's the fact that I don't have
a barn in which to house a Pegasus also
there's the not-insignificant cost of
hay plus I've always found flying pets
to be kind of more trouble than they're
worth
hey where do the Ducks go when the pond
freezes over they migrate south except
in the actual case of Holden Caufield
wondering what happens to the ducks in
the Central Park pond they do not
migrate south because the pond never
freezes over as the official
photographer for Central Park put it I
don't know what Salinger was thinking
I've worked at the park for 27 years and
have always seen ducks in the winter
have you ever been tempted to get
nerdfighters to tame honey badgers so
you could have a Broadway musical
starring honey badgers yeah I can see
the headline now man convinces children
to tame honey badgers for strange
Broadway musical seven dead including no
honey badgers hank dftba i will see you
on Friday